finally new rules stop trying to pin the
rise of Donald Trump on easy targets
like racism xenophobia and fetal alcohol
syndrome
and put the blame where it belongs on
the self-esteem movement the most
important person in the whole wide the
most important person in the whole see
what I mean if there's anything scarier
than the fact that Donald Trump thinks
he's the most important person in the
world it's not in eight months he could
be now
pundits have been all over the map
lately trying to explain the Trump
phenomenon he's a con man he's a
Klansman he's a clown someone even keeps
saying he's born of an orangutan
but what Donald Trump really reminds me
of is a spoiled five-year-old throwing a
tantrum he is the grownup version of
every pain-in-the-ass kid who ever sat
behind you on a plane kicking the back
of your seat while the parents did
nothing hmm little Logan is just
exploring you know little Logan is being
a dick and if you won't shove him in the
overhead bin I will
every time a parent takes the kids side
over the teachers or asks a child where
they want to go to dinner or doesn't say
be quiet when adults are talking you are
creating the Donald Trump's of tomorrow
these are the parents who put notes in
their kids lunchbox that say I love you
when there's already something in the
lunchbox that lets kids know you love
them food now I don't know if you
remember this song and maybe you'll help
me by singing it singing a wine from it
would you yes yes yes learning to love
yourself is the greatest love of all
awesome voice awesome song bad idea bad
I did it teach children that there is
nothing better than falling madly
head-over-heels leaving notes on your
own windshield in love with yourself and
also that anyone who doesn't agree that
you are fabulous and perfect in every
way is just a hater and they can suck it
sound like anyone we know have you
noticed that nobody ever does anything
better than Donald Trump I would build a
great wall and nobody builds walls
better than me believe me I will be the
greatest jobs president that God ever
created nobody knows the system better
than me nobody would be tougher on Isis
than Donald Trump nobody loves the Bible
more than I do there's nobody bigger or
better at the military than I am I could
be more presidential than anybody
he's the white Kanye West
I just want a reporter one time to ask
him about humility so I can hear him say
there was nobody better at being humble
than me nobody loves the Bible more
nice try Pope Francis unfortunately for
you you're in the same world with Donald
Trump unfortunately for all of us but
kind of predictable Trump is the perfect
candidate for the country that scores
low in math and science but off the
charts in self esteem yeah a study of
APE developed countries found that US
students were dead last in math skills
but number one in confidence in math
skills even though they suck at it
yes we're number one in thinking we're
number one and when the numbers don't
validate that confidence well we know
who the real culprit is those stupid
numbers so we changed them in the 1960s
at Yale ten percent of all grades were
A's
now it's 62 percent this is called
trophy syndrome where no one ever loses
and everyone gets a prize you can run
the wrong way on the field and score
five goals for the other team and you're
still a winner even though you're
actually a big [ __ ] loser and
and this isn't just kids
NBA players give each other high-fives
when they miss a foul shot
Oprah gets a big round of applause for
losing weight and another one for having
the courage to put it back on we tell
our children they don't have to fix
their flaws because it's the world job
to accept everything about them and love
it like they say on reality shows the
most important thing is just you doing
you but what if you is a big [ __ ]
so you can vote for Donald Trump if you
want but never think that for him it's
about the country he doesn't even really
want to be president he just wants to be
called presidents because he is the
logical result of 40 years of
worshipping at the altar of self-esteem
where everything is about you and every
kid gets a trophy wife
you